what should people be doing to protect
themselves - you know maximize the
strength of their immunity to stay safe
in this time other obviously than
physical distancing right so the first
thing I would say is if you smoke stop
immediately that's number one
hopefully all your viewers and listeners
don't smoke but that's that's the
biggest risk you can inflict on your
body in the in the carbon 19 era is to
be a smoker but you can actually recover
pretty quickly if you stop so now will
be the time for those of you who of
those of us who are not smokers you
still can optimize your body you want to
do some aerobics as it's called or
high-intensity interval training if
you're just in an apartment you can
still do what are they jumping jacks Tom
what do we call you star jumps that's
the minimum
I'll get your heart moving you probably
have noticed I'm actually standing up
for this interview I really try to avoid
sitting down because you know I'm
burning calories getting more flexible
my body is much better off than sitting
when I wrote my book for two years I
could barely walk after that my muscles
were so degraded in my hips so that
brings another point you want to be
doing flexibility and hip hinge
exercises in general especially as you
get older but specifically fall of a
virus you don't want to be low in iron
so if you typically have some anemia
make sure you're not any because you
need your blood to be able to bring your
oxygen levels up I would focus my time
indeed
now there's really good evidence from
studies and doctors advise that vitamin
D will keep your immune system in
tip-top shape so I'm taking
two-and-a-half thousand units a day of
that shows my family I eat I still eat
less often than most people I'm still
skipping breakfast I think a little bit
of fasting during the day can only have
benefits for immune system as long as
you don't overdo it and stop eating for
a whole week I'm also trying to keep my
blood sugar levels Lord
you know not too low that I'm passing
out but what some Chinese scientists
have published is that the virus can
also attack red blood cells where you
have iron of course carries oxygen and
it's also thought that you can damage
your red blood cells the hemoglobin by
having too much sure and in fact if you
have a lot of blood so that when you get
a test for type 2 diabetes - what
they're measuring is a thing called
hba1c and the H B stands for hemoglobin
and the it's basically sugars attached
to your hemoglobin which have been
speculated to make your blood red blood
cells more susceptible to the virus so
in an abundance of caution and if you
have type 2 diabetes
it certainly can't hurt you and will
probably help you to eat less often
during the day I still have really great
dinners I eat normally and I have a
glass of red wine
typically with dinner so I'm not always
eating carrots so I'm with you you got
to live a little in life but now would
be the time to get into shape the most
important thing people can do for their
immune system is sleep I think of all of
the levers we pull you know getting
eight hours of sleep a night is gonna
move the needle as much as any I think
other things that matter are exercising
every day but not doing it at at super
high intensity so kind of two types of
people right there are people that don't
exercise enough generally they need to
be exercising more and then there are
probably people like you and I who
exercise a lot and probably exercise a
little too much and a little too intense
we have to actually dial it back so I'm
you know really focusing on exercising
every day but only about an hour and not
at the level of intensity that I would
normally and you know a lot of it's just
body weight stuff it's just sort of
moving it's just being active and it's
as important for my head as it is for my
my body with respect to food that's been
a huge challenge for me you know I tend
to stress eat a little more than I would
care to admit so I've been kind of just
focusing on doing more time restricted
feeding it's just a little easier for me
to be binary
and you know at least say okay how about
I just don't need anything for these 18
or 20 hours as opposed to allowing
myself the liberty of stress grazing
what can someone do to shore up their
immune system while this is all going on
well a couple things
first of all just being as healthy as
you can be you know wait wait you know
I'm I'm getting up there right now or
you know becomes more of a challenge to
stay you know in good shape you know the
more you can do to do that something you
know all about you know is keeping in
shape is really important a second thing
is if you're on medications like for
blood pressure
don't don't miss them take those drugs
because they're really important even
though they may not appear simple you
know you don't have any symptoms a high
blood pressure or something like that
and then I think just you know getting
sleep and eating a healthy diet and
that's about what we can do today to
help get you prepared for this what else
can people do in terms of all this hand
sanitizer jazz and masks is that all
yeah the hand sanitizers actually are a
great thing for stopping a lot of
infectious diseases they actually are
really good they're good for your hands
you know in terms of the skin they kill
the bad bugs but the whole issue of
using your hands touching your face of
people all concentrate on yes the data
is actually very weak that this what
kind of virus is gonna be transmitted
that way so I wouldn't tell you to stop
using hand sanitizers but don't think
it's gonna have a big impact on this
book do you see that viral video that's
going around that woman who was giving
the address at the behest of the White
House and she see that she tells people
not to touch their face and then
immediately licks her finger and I did
age yeah I saw that I saw that well why
is she telling people not to touch their
faces because you know well the the
thought was is that there are receptors
around your eye right here that actually
for this virus could get in and then get
into your body and you know the data we
have on this is so sparse to say that
that's the case I think the primary
thing about hand-washing is legitimate
but one of the things we want people
want to do something they want to be
able to think they're doing something
and so we tell them wash your hands
often in to present this to prevent this
disease and I feel like we're not being
really honest with the people that the
and and we've looked at this very
carefully really is about just breathing
error and that's a hard thing to stop so
keep doing the hand-washing but don't
think that that's going to stop this
disease which you asked about the man to
stop other stuff yes yeah it works
there's two kinds right basically the
surgical mask which just fits over and
the reason it's called a surgical mask
is because it's loose-fitting just fits
you know kind of ties behind you because
weren't worn by surgeons so that they
don't cough or drip into your wound
right and it was never made to protect
you from bugs coming in so those little
spaces on the sides that's not a problem
if I'm breathing into the cloth right in
front of my nose but in terms of the air
coming in on the side they're not
they're not effective at all so people
wear them they look like they're doing
something or not now if you are sick
they may help a little bit from you
transmitting because if you cough then
you cough right into that cloth and it
will somewhat it'll embed in there and
not get out around the other one though
is called an in 95 respirator but for
all intents first looks like a mask it's
just tight face fitting it has the seal
unit the nose etc that's an apocalypse
mask it could be I don't know what those
are but that's good yes I'm just saying
that that's how I look at it okay okay
well they're actually we use them all
the time in health care all the time and
they use them in action about 90% of
them are used in industry so there are
grinding things or asbestos etc you know
they don't breathe in all these parts so
if we have one of those that'll do some
they're very effective they're very
picked - the problem is we have a big
shortage you know right now we have
hospitals that are down to just a couple
days worth of these mask respirators and
it's because we don't stockpile anything
in this country you know we don't have
hospitals don't have the money to do
that those Preppers right now are so
excited yeah all the preppers across the
guy I knew it I knew the day would come
yeah well they are they aren't an
teaches and well you know but well this
is really important because how health
care workers go is how the country I
think will see we're going you know
there been over 4,000 health care
workers in China who are infected
mininum on their job and a number of
them died and if in this country we have
a real challenge delivering health care
because we're overwhelmed and then we
have health care workers picking up the
infection like we talked about the group
and
one and we don't have the protection for
them I really believe that's when the
public will say wait a minute what's
going on here when we have all these
terrible situations going on and we
can't change anything what can you do
well the first thing is to understand
that you can stay the same all around
there is panic and worry and hysteria
but you can stay the same you can do it
always done got up looked after your
house do your job if you can do your job
being a parent a spouse a friend so the
first thing the most important thing is
to remember this will pass we don't know
what's going to happen but you have to
know I'm going to be okay I'm going to
do everything to be okay because when
you're stressed and anxious and worried
it upsets your immune system your immune
system doesn't like stress doesn't like
worry know what it likes it likes
calmness
it likes positivity it likes knowing
that everything is going to be okay so
we're all stuck in our home me too I'm
on the other side of the world from the
people I love the most but I make a
decision every day my life is good so
you need to get up get out of that put
your clothes on you need to do the most
basic things to make you well that means
eating well hydrating sleeping it's very
easy in terms of crisis to go I'm just
gonna eat lots of cakes and lie on the
sofa and binge watch TV because what
else can I do and I get that you can lie
on the sofa binge watch TV but do not
eat loads of cakes because sugar is an
enemy of your immune system yes you can
have a little bit of something but the
hardest thing when you're feeling stress
is do the very things you don't want to
do you don't want to exercise you don't
want to eat well but that's what you
must do create a place in your home and
exercise every day
because it massively boosts your immune
system meditate if you can and I'm going
to release today an amazing meditation
to boost your immune system your immune
system is your last line of defense when
you can't get drugs and we're being told
that really there are no drugs for this
virus but the best drug you have is in
you exercise to boost your immune system
use the meditation I'm going to give you
or any other meditation to boost your
immune system eat foods that boost your
immune system particularly vegetables
and things high in vitamin C hydrate a
lot and what is the fifth thing use your
mind
thoughts are things when you get into oh
my god it's all doom and gloom the world
as I know will never be the same again
you're weakening your immune system be
positive how can you be positive look
don't we all go gosh I'd love some time
for myself I never have enough time
we're now time is forced upon us to use
that time sort out your house clear out
staff learned something new read those
books do an online course work out a
home do anything you can so remember you
have at least five things you can do do
some form of exercise every day meditate
every day eat right sleep right hydrate
but more than anything else use your
mind to stay calm you know I can think
in my lifetime of so many things
HIV SARS the Gulf War we were told
repeatedly life will never be the same
again never ever be the same again and
you know what it did go back to being
the same again and I think it will go
back to being the same again but you
have a brilliant mind and here's your
choice because we always have a choice
in a crisis what choice do you have will
you have to rationalize why you feel so
terrible or talk yourself out of it the
way you feel about everything including
this fire
it's down to the pictures you make in
your head and the words you say to
yourself and if the pictures are nothing
is going to be the same again
this is an epochal X it's all going to
go terribly wrong it's all doom and
gloom you will feel like that even if
it's not true and if you do the other
well this is a blip it's unfortunate
what can I find that's good about it
I've a lot of time for me then you will
feel different what does it mean to be
recovered and can you get the virus a
second time and if yes or no does that
influence you know how testing kind of
goes in the futures trying to detect an
antibody or even a dress like that
conversation around murder immunity and
how to really not let this be a cyclical
thing that or is it or is it a cyclical
thing in terms of you know what's
expected in the future okay step yet can
you get the virus a second time let's
get to the first one which was also
important all right if you're infected
and you recover the question is what can
you go out and be safe to not infect
others the general rule is you have to
have two cultures 24 hours apart that
are negative that's our focus now as
more people get infected that likely is
not going to be feasible so we're gonna
have to set some guidelines up days
following the diminution of symptoms
we're not there yet
cuz we don't know as much about how far
out you could be shedding virus bursting
second day your main question once you
get infected can you get reinfected we
haven't done the specific testing to
determine that but if this acts like
every virus similar to it that we know
the chances are all the whelming that if
you get infected recover from infection
that you are not gonna get infected with
the same virus which means you can then
safely go out into the community and
feel immune so that you could not only
protect yourself
get back to work get back to your job
but you'll be able to have what you
refer to as herd immunity enough people
who recovered in the community that
gives the virus very little chance to
spread rapidly
that's what's referred to as herd
immunity everybody until this is over
[ __ ] should practice some degree of
physical distant singing care not big
crowds wash your hands a lot be careful
you can do that and still get back to
somewhat of a normal life there's a big
difference between the extreme of
locking a city down right opening it up
a bit but being more careful than you
normally would be and I think there are
places in the country now where you want
to look at carefully and said you know
maybe you want to pull back a little bit
on the restriction so long as you just
don't let it rip and say I don't care
what happens sorry
you treat New York City a little bit
different do we treat Nebraska do I have
any tips for starting the day positively
in this coronavirus situation like every
day I do and take the cold shower I take
the cold shower which wakes me up and
then I want to go everywhere because I
got so much energy now I go into
breathing breathing exercises and from
the breathing exercises which tilts my
mind in the deep I'm subtly aware and
just being there being here amazing
feeling that's the way to start the day
eventually a push-up exercise after
doing 30 breaths is an amazing jolt of
adrenaline rushing through you then you
are able to start into any other way
because you have still Germont and you
have still to body through the cold
shower the breathing exercises and the
push ups exercise you're really on from
there we can go anywhere this is the way
I start my day every day be preventative
me and get healthy right now
load up on vitamin C
load up on vitamin D B+ okay don't don't
pass on all the rumors in the gossip and
the garbage and the [ __ ] take time
to be quiet within yourself and like say
get clear about where you're going these
are these are great times by the way
this to invest in yourself and start
really clearing out the garbage 2008 was
great for me changed my whole life
okay 2020 it's going to be great for me
and many others clean up clean up your
inventory clean out your life get rid of
the people in your life that are that
have been negative that it may be making
you say I think what people need to
realize is that you know for your own
health and for protecting our community
at large it's important for us to take
care of our health because one we know
that sugar and starch and processed food
are immune suppressive that they're
going to actually make your body less
able to fight the coronavirus so for
your own self-interest the important
thing is to eat a lot of protective
foods that are going to boost immunity
that are going to make you more
resilient less likely to get sick and to
not eat all this stuff that you think is
comfort food but it's actually going to
make you more sick and it's also you
know important for for the bigger
problem which is the burden on the
health care system because if more of us
don't take care of ourselves more of a
suppresser immunity by not doing the
things we need to do for self-care and
food in particular we're gonna get sick
we're gonna go to the healthcare system
we're gonna burden the hospitals it is
going to be worse so I think there's an
argument to be made both you know for
your own health and as well as a social
conscience to actually focus on taking
care of your own health and I think
there are a lot of ways to eat delicious
comfort food so for example I made the
other night like pasta right but I used
chickpea pasta which is high in protein
there's no gluten and I made this
incredible you know Puttanesca which was
very cheap very cheap is like it was
called the horse pasta from Naples which
is a said you know anchovies and capers
and olives and tomatoes and olive oil
and garlic and onions and it's
incredibly warm and comfort
and you can make delicious food I'm
eating chicken soup which is again
lasted us for four days or the one
chicken and tons of root vegetables so
it doesn't have to be expensive and it
doesn't have to even take that long but
I think I think now is the time when we
have time at home when we can get still
fresh food when we actually can cook a
little bit because if people start using
this time at home that they were
commuting or driving to work or people
are off work starting self-care is going
to make you happier you less depressed
you feel better and also making much
less likely you're gonna get sick or if
you get sick or gonna be able to fight
it off some of the data right now
indicates that there are a lot more
younger people in America being
hospitalized with coronavirus between
the ages of 20 to 58 and you know people
say gee why would that be because you
know these people 20 30 years old they
are healthy but I'm sorry to report the
reality is that the youth of America are
not necessarily healthy we rank in
America at least 46 in terms of health
care on the global scale was very high
rates of obesity and so we're not really
super healthy as it relates to so many
chronic degenerative conditions high
rates of obesity high rates of diabetes
which we know are associated with worse
outcome as it relates to coronavirus so
this is a real call to younger people to
take the preliminary information about
distancing themselves very seriously
that's your best defense in a situation
where we don't have an offense another
question my HS asses what's the
correlation of kovat and sense of smell
yeah interesting Lee there's been some
reports of loss of sense of smell as
being the Harbinger for this having
further symptoms not exactly sure why
but it may be that you know the the
cilia are rather the the nerve endings
in your nose that are involved in
transmitting sent to the brain might be
colonized with the virus and then lose
their function Sanjay Gupta I think was
one of the earliest to call that out and
some think about what we're talking
about is a complete change in lifestyle
for the next three months six months and
maybe even longer we just have to
realize all over the world that we are
now in a pandemic this is unprecedented
we've never had this in our lifetimes
before and we're going to have to live
differently now we will get through this
things will go back to normal but for
the next six months we're really going
to have to accommodate to preventing and
delaying the spread of this virus and
yes that will mean lots of social
distancing that means meticulous hygiene
it means avoiding crowded places
especially indoors it means things like
staggering the way at times we go to
work so that there's not lots of people
crowded together on public transport it
means working at home as much as we can
and them generally avoid going out it
means stopping shaking hands it means
stopping huggers and social kisses we
have to have this social distancing
because this virus only survives inside
human cells it's only going to go from
one person's respiratory system into
another's and if we can break that chain
of transmission in as many cases as we
can then we're going to greatly delay
that curve
push push the peak back into summer
preferably back into late summer when we
have less people with influenza and
other chronic winter related diseases in
our hospitals and flatten that curve
down so that less people are going to be
sick at any one period of time that is
now the aim if you want more advice
wisdom guidance from other successful
entrepreneurs on how you can navigate
the coronavirus situation check out the
video right there next to me I hope you
find it valuable and continue to believe
and I'll see you there do fun like
actually do [ __ ] that's fun